So the more we look at polling, the more we
might think that Joe Biden and Kamala Harris
have this election in the bag.
But consider for a moment that even if the
polls are both perfectly accurate and don't
change between now and Election Day, what
about voter suppression?
Because the Supreme Court just showed us that
at least three of the justices are more than
willing to throw out absentee ballots.
And that is not priced into the polls in any
way.
The Supreme Court has reinstated South Carolina's
witness signature requirement for absentee
ballots.
They did this earlier this week.
That alone is a decision that could decide
whether Lindsey Graham is reelected as a Republican
incumbent in South Carolina or whether Challenger
date.
Jamie Harrison from the Democratic Party removes
incumbent Lindsey Graham.
That is what the stakes are here.
And it means that South Carolinians, including
those infected with Corona virus, will once
again need witnesses to sign their ballot
envelopes.
So think that through for a second.
You have corona virus or you want to avoid
getting it.
You have it and want to avoid spreading it.
Or you shouldn't go out or you want to avoid
getting it from someone else.
You just want to be as safe as possible.
You request an absentee ballot.
Beautiful.
You get the absentee ballot.
Perfect.
You fill out the absentee ballot correctly.
Lovely.
But before you send it in.
You need to find a witness to sign the envelope
for you that says it's really you voting.
It's really you sending this thing.
And it's pointless because that signature
could, of course, before it risks spreading
the virus.
And it will almost certainly lead to the nullification
of ballots.
But that's not the worst of it.
It's even worse potentially because Justices
Clarence Thomas, Samuel Alito and Neil Gorsuch
would have been willing not just to say that
these ballots going forward must have a witness
signature, but Thomas, Alito and Gorsuch actually
were ready to say this rule should be applied
retroactively.
So I really need people to understand this.
Clarence Thomas, Samuel Alito and Neil Gorsuch
would be onboard with saying ballots already
received by South Carolina election officials
before this decision was made about witness
signatures.
Those ballots should be thrown out, even though
at the time that folks sent their ballots
in this witness signature rule was not yet
the rule.
It is outrageous and extreme.
And what it signals to me is that if indeed
they get Amy Kelt CONI Barat confirmed to
the Supreme Court and if indeed this entire
presidential election starts to extend into
November and starts to involve courts, there
are already three.
Amy CONI Barrett could be a fourth.
And then you then it's just a question mark.
What will John Roberts do?
What will others do?
They are willing to actually interfere in
ways that are material.
These are not theoretical things.
These are not things that might have an impact.
But two or four years from now, this is right
now.
And had they gotten this rule passed, the
retroactive requirement for witness signatures,
that would have led to I don't even know how
many ballots being thrown out that could have
led to Lindsey Graham winning, even if Jamie
Harrison would otherwise have won.
I mean, we don't know.
That's going to be a tight race and it's an
uphill battle for Jamie Harrison.
But the point here is the Trump administration
is going to use this to their advantage in
any way that they can.
The Trump campaign has an army of lawyers
ready to do anything they can in any state.
They can do it to see what they can get away
with.
Biden has a team of lawyers.
But are they ready?
As I've said before, it's much more difficult
to play defense because you need to anticipate
every strategy that Trump can use.
Trump might have 10 different strategies lawyers
will use and Biden's lawyers might anticipate
nine of them.
And it could be that tenth one that actually
gets you in the end.
So they really need to be prepared because
Trump wants to win.
Trump, at this point can only win by preventing
people from voting, by dissuading people from
voting, by having people's votes not counted.
And Republicans have repeatedly said in public
that this is the plan.
No one should be surprised now that they are
actually making the plan a reality.
And if it comes to just a couple of states,
which it might, and the Supreme Court invalidates
hundreds of thousands of votes, more than
that, will there be a revolt?
I actually think, you know, I don't have.
I have what I think is a realistic assessment
that most people cannot.
Or to miss the next day of work and most people
are not going to mass rally and go protest
because they have people to feed and money
to make and bills to pay.
And I understand that.
But I actually think that if it appears as
though a Supreme Court with multiple justices
on it selected by Donald Trump in starts invalidating
votes and potentially flips the election to
Trump, I do believe there will be complete
actual chaos in the streets.
I believe we will see mass rallies.
I do believe that.
And I rarely am of that mindset.
Let me know what you think